tous les amateurs richard berner se
promène dans les bois depuis maintenant
plusieurs jours coprin l'acteur reçu les
tricolores n'ont pas de secret pour lui
et il connaît les dangers de cette
cueillette
c'est le champignon qu'il faut connaître
avant tous les autres c'est le
champignon le peu dangereux qui soit en
europe qui est responsable de 99% mais
l'intoxication mortelle en europe c'est
l'amanite phalloïde et sa des amanites
phalloïdes y en a beaucoup ici il y en a
beaucoup ici c'est un champignon très
courant qui est vraiment à champignons
mortels 50 grammes suffisent à tuer un
adulte quelques décès mais surtout près
de 10 mille intoxication liée aux
champignons par an en france
six à sept cents nécessitant une
hospitalisation et le premier
empoisonneurs lantheaume lignes vides
qui est à une très très belle qui sent
bon qui est très joli et qui peut se
confondre avec certains champignons qui
pourrait être comestible
alors c'était sous des chaînes parce que
là où je suis allé donc aux forêts de
châteauroux j'avais il y avait pas mal
de taper l'endroit où il y avait les
chaises les sangliers avaient beaucoup
fouiner et à la revoilà on peut le coupé
voir si la coulure évolué elle a déjà on
appelle en dise accéder raboteux poli
raboteux est comestible mais sans plus
alors à éviter comme tous les
champignons que l'on ne connaît pas pour
info la plupart des intoxications ont
logiquement lieu en octobre au plus fort
de la saison des champignons